[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause] [
Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
I am the Bianchi vineyard I come from
Civitanova Marche and I am a
municipal councilor we have Giacomo Cona I am from
Verona I am a municipal councilor
delegate for European policies Marco
zipparri mayor of Marsicovetere a
town of 6000 inhabitants in the
Lucano hinterland I am Irene falchini
city councilor delegate of the mayor for equal
opportunities and gender policies
international cooperation twinning
of the municipality of Sesto Fiorentino
my Veronese community needs to
start over  process of
approaching the European Union
also becoming a protagonist in the
debate within the
European institutions as a city as a community as a
territory and therefore my role here is
to create a bridge a
connection between Verona and the
European Union to the European institution my
presence  it is important to divulge Here
's
That aspect that today
our citizens see in a different way
our children that unfortunately there
is this gap between the south and Europe
Italy and Europe it is important to
participate because participation is
one of the founding values ​​of the
European Union and doing it above all with what are
the representations of
political representatives of a territory
increases the very value of the
European Union makes it clear that the territories are important
[Music] I
also expect you to be able to have a
preferential channel if  we want
communication with the management with the
European community to also carry
forward
the needs of the needs, including
training needs, for the growth of us
local administrators and also of the
citizens. The fundamental points
is precisely the need to build a
European citizenship, therefore to make
citizens feel like members of the
local communities part of something
bigger and of a project which is precisely
the European one
[Music]